this new york post columnist and uh a
writer of many bestsellers uh his next
book coming out perfect timing called
coach k the rise and reign of mike
shishevsky and you can pre-order that
where all books are acquired ian
o'connor of the new york post joining us
here on the rich island show how you
doing
hey rich good to be with you
i'm doing all right so um
john mara is chatting with the media
right now um and um he is saying it was
gut-wrenching to fire
joe judge uh i saw your piece in the new
york post in which you said that
what uh mara and steve tisch did uh by
firing joe judge needed to be done why
did you have that stance
well actually just i just got off the
zoom call with john mara i was surprised
rich that the back-to-back quarterback
sneaks
uh in the final game of course which
reminded those of us old enough of the
joe bizarchic the famous fumble in 1978
which marked a very dark period in
giants history he said that was just a
minor factor in the decision
and and so i think the the post-game
press conference the 11-minute manifesto
from the podium after the chicago game
that was a factor but it was more that
once they lost their quarterback the
operation just completely unraveled and
he said john mara said
i thought that we had dug ourselves such
a hole that there was no way out
and so if he's being honest it was
really a culmination of what happened
really after daniel jones got hurt
and they didn't have a viable backup
quarterback and the entire franchise in
operation just came undone
and and that was the reason i i really
believe that he was john mara has always
been a guy who looks for reasons to keep
people not fire them and i still think
sunday he was looking for a reason to
retain joe judge for year three so my
personal opinion is that back to back
quarterback sneak sequence had more to
do with it than maybe john let on today
i i that that's what caused me to to
come to this microphone in this chair um
on monday
um ian and say essentially what you
would were writing in the in in the new
york post
i've never seen that before it's a
surrender formation you know it's the
exact opposite of victory formation it's
a surrender
formation and a professional football
team should have a play regardless of
who is at quarterback or anywhere else
on the field that can convert a third
down regardless of where you are on the
field certainly in a three-nothing game
certainly against a a team in your
division certainly a team in your
division that you bizarrely called out
you know from the podium
that to me is just like how does that
happen
and i saw that and i thought to myself
how does this guy stay
that's the way i went with it
that that's exactly the way i went with
it too rich and if you recall the giant
started a super bowl run from the one
yard line on that victor cruz christmas
eve 99-yard touchdown so you can play
football backed up against your own end
zone the giants proved that 10 years ago
when they won their last title
and so yeah the surrender not only was
it
got off on at the end of a four and 13
season in five miserable years
seven double figure lost seasons in the
last eight but here's a coach who in his
introductory press conference said every
play
under me will have a life of its own we
are going to attack every play with
relentless spirit and be and i remember
having a conversation with him on the
phone where i brought up the fact that
obviously he's a
a disciple of belichick and saban and he
he turned the conversation away from
those two figures toward parcells and
coughlin said i want to be associated
with those two people for two reasons
they won championships with the giants
that's what i want to do and the
physicality of their teams in in
december
weatherproof football team that that
matches up with the ethos of the new
york new jersey region and i want to put
that product on the field and then he
did that
on sunday to those people the 30 40 000
who showed up and to those who were
watching that to me was unforgivable he
could not coach another second for the
new york giants after he did that you
know conor the new york post here on the
rich eisen show so then what is the
issue
what can you put your finger on because
again um john mara's dad's nickname is
on the football i mean he's been around
he's it's football of a football man as
there is
he is also involved in the competition
committee and a very influential owner
in the national football league the fact
that his franchise and i know half of it
belongs to steve tish as well
is sputtering like this after
uh joe judge comes
after pat shermer who came after ben
mcadoo who was allowed to bench eli and
smash that record-setting
streak of consecutive starts in favor of
a jet quarterback who the city had a
front-row seat
for his mediocrity for years
that was allowed to happen what is the
issue
with the giants
you know well if you if you go back 10
years john marrow is considered one of
the best owners in the nfl they had won
two championships in five years
and and so he was asked this question
today is it a fundamental breakdown
inside the organization as far as
evaluating personnel or is it a
disconnected series of bad decisions and
he said all of the above what i'll say
is this he was a good owner when he had
a good gm a good head coach and a good
quarterback now he had a terrible gm
who's now gone a terrible coach who's
now gone and then injured quarterback
that we're not sure about
so
i think you tie it back to the 2018
draft and hanging on to eli manning too
long those those things are very
connected if dave gettleman takes josh
allen at number two instead of saquon
barkley we're probably not having this
discussion the giants to me
i'm not saying they would have developed
josh allen the way the bills did but
they might be the sixth seed in in the
tournament today instead of a complete
wasteland
so
hanging on to eli too long not drafting
the right quarterback in 2018 taking a
running back there at number two
and then
and then daniel jones i i think he's got
a lot of physical talent but
he doesn't stay on the field and as you
know rich that's the most important
talent for any quarterback to have
availability tom brady
is the master of that and eli manning of
course was as well
so
that's why the giants are where they are
no i know i know you know the the
i guess road to what perdition
you know but uh what about
you know the the question and answer
that was asked of john mara about
at the center of all this because there
is a general manager you know that's
gonna have to be hired and dave
gettleman was the one who made those
decisions and that was the decision of
john mara to make and
and and all of the coaches that have
have been here um
it's been positively dreadful as we all
know what about is there going to be
a change within the organization
from mara and everything else on the way
they've done any everything what was
gleaned out of that conversation uh the
change is that they're going outside the
family for a general manager for the
first time in forever
you go back to george young ernie corzi
jerry reese dave gettleman that that's
all in the family right they were all
giants lifers basically i'd be starting
with uh accordsy after george young who
was put in of course by pete roselle
so they're now going to hire a general
manager outside the organization that's
going to be the big change and then
allow that person to make the head
coaching hard kevin abrams who's been in
that uh giant franchise for more than 20
years he was groomed to be the next in
in line in the succession of giant
executives to take over they're not even
giving him an interview so
so that is the change the mara family
will still be there john said today the
gm and head coach will always make the
decisions i'll give the final okay
99.9 percent of the time unless there's
an off the field conduct issue i will
approve as long as the gm and head coach
are in agreement
and so
so that's the change they're finally
going to hire a general manager from
another organization probably with zero
ties to the giants
and see how it plays out from there yeah
and then and then that guy will really
just just or lady decide who the the
coach is like that's it and then and
then we'll play it like that right
that's the way it's gonna go yeah and
then make the decision too on the
quarterback yeah what's the scoop there
what do you think i mean obviously he's
under contract they're gonna use him
next year if he's healthy he's cleared
what in august for contact that's a
serious neck injury the guy had this
year there's a serious neck injury and
now frankly i've written this so i if if
russell wilson is available and he may
not be i would pursue that i think the
giants have to pursue that
they have two top 10 draft picks yep so
they have draft capital they don't have
salary cap space so the new gem is going
to have to be awfully creative as far as
making something like that work i i do
think daniel jones has the athleticism
the size and the arm to be a good nfl
quarterback but he just hasn't been able
to stay healthy and put all that
together and he doesn't seem to elevate
people around him he's had a bad roster
but nobody seems to get better around
daniel jones so that's a bit of a
problem and uh my guess is rich that the
new gm will come in and and give daniel
jones next year and then make
his or her determination on the
quarterback long term and what do you
what are you thinking about coaches what
are you hearing i know you you're i know
that the general manager has to decide
but this is this is a this is a gig
that um
you know uh uh
everybody keeps saying i don't know if
he'd want to do it you just throw a
blank check at bill cower and go for it
you know um or somebody somebody who's
been there and a huge splash
but also somebody who knows the league
and somebody outside the family you know
like that's the idea too
right so what do you think
i think if i had to place twenty dollars
on it today i'd probably bet on joe
shane as the general manager and brian
uh dabo as the head coach
but i i think brian flores should be the
head coach
okay
i like him a lot i think he was what 24
and 25 in three years in miami with
quarterbacks who aren't as physically
talented as daniel jones he beat
belichick four times in three years
uh the relationship situation down there
with the general manager and ownership
i don't cover the dolphins so i don't
know what happened there what went wrong
but
i think brian flores is a really good
candidate i'm not sure the giants are
going to hire him
and of course it comes down to what the
general manager prefers
another person to watch here
would be in baltimore uh joe ortiz uh he
is very well regarded and even though he
was the ninth general manager candidate
id'd as far as getting an interview i
think he could be a serious player in
this to me shane is probably the guy to
beat
but ortiz
could could be a serious factor here a
lot of people he comes out of a great
organization when it comes to evaluating
personnel ozzie newsome de costa those
guys are great
so
he could be a major factor as well
what's your take on what's going on with
the nets just switching gears a little
bit here what's your take on their their
reversal of uh
half of kyrie's better than no kyrie
i didn't like it
i thought they sold a piece of their
soul i understand their their rationale
i i just listen i gave them a lot of
credit for taking the initial stand that
they took
and and then to kind of just throw it
all away
i i didn't like it kyrie irving is is a
fabulous point guard and watching him
play
is is actually a treat
oh it is uh i remember talking to bob
cousy about him bob kuzie said he's one
of the five best point guards he's ever
seen as far as running a team
and so it is fun to watch but i don't
think it was fun to see how the nets
played that out and
and i don't wish him any will of course
but
i would not have made that move
and i guess last one for you here your
uh your um new books coming out right on
shishevsky um
so uh
walk me through how long you've been
you've been on the trail
yeah and you were kind enough to have me
on rich for my belgium book i really
appreciated that of course uh so it was
a similar process but the difference was
uh bill belichick was sort of lobbying
people not to talk to me i think coach k
hasn't done that and so i appreciate
that he hasn't created those kinds of
obstacles
and so it's talking hundreds of people
about a great american life and leader
and
and uh i didn't know when i started the
process of course that he was going to
announce this would be his final season
so i guess i'm glad he didn't end it
last season
uh very glad but i i think they're good
enough to win the whole thing i think uh
i'm hoping this is the most definitive
honest accurate and fair account of his
life that's my plan that's my hope and i
guess i'll leave it up to the readers to
decide yeah because i guess that that
would be next up on the national media
hit parade
once the nfl season is concluded it's
the final six weeks of coach k's
coaching career and what duke might be
able to do with it by putting him on a
a ladder with a pair of scissors right i
mean like
just like john wooden at the end so
it would be fitting for him to go out
with number six no question about it and
and the good news is they're good enough
to do it i don't know if they're the
best team i think baylor probably is but
i saw them live against kentucky i've
watched them on tv
they are good enough to win the whole
thing ban caro is unbelievable
uh so it would be a hell of a story for
them to to actually pull that off and
then how about you talk about a story
right i mean what if and this was real
and this was real a few weeks ago and
we're
you know mack jones's uh final four
games certainly has put uh a damper on
things but new england getting back in
the playoffs with the quarterback that
belichick drafted
specifically within mind to turn the
brady page
that is truly something what do you
think's going through his brain
this week
you know first yeah first of all rich i
think it's it's really good for football
and in the nfl for him to be back in the
in the tournament with with another
quarterback i think it's a really cool
thing i'm fascinated to watch
how this is going to work if they're
going to be able to advance
and no i i do know that there there's a
number of years and he told people i had
this in my book that he was
as great as much as he respected tom
brady and understood everything brady
did for bill's legacy that he did at
some point look forward to the day where
he had another quarterback to try to win
with that player well now he has that
player
and so i i think he'll he'll be coaching
for another four or five years into his
70s he originally said he wouldn't do
that but he's a he's a young man
for his age he's 10 15 years younger
than his age the way he acts and carries
himself so i would be surprised if he's
not still coaching mac jones five years
from now i mean i don't know if you can
go deep into your notes your just your
mental uh you know uh notes of uh of
your you know interviews about belichick
did you ever find out uh at any point in
time what a new year's resolution was
for him because we tried a couple times
somebody tried a couple times and
weren't able to
get it from him did you see that did you
see that i did i did after after he
loses to the bills
oh my god
i do give that reporter as tom brady did
a lot of credit for having the nerve to
ask that question after a loss
i was a little disappointed when she
asked a second time
that he i thought he'd give that answer
come on bill just because he said maybe
next week and then she did in fact
return
right you know right but
that's when i thought come on give the
answer now he did he didn't smile he did
smile so he gave him that but that would
have been a great opportunity for him to
to show something there so i was a
little disappointed he didn't come
through with an answer yeah and today i
don't know you might have been in you
might have been in that zoom with john
mara uh bill showed up today with a cut
off sweatshirt that uh it looks like
it's a top gun sweatshirt i don't know
it says it says danger zone on it um ian
i don't know did you get anything from
his history was he a big top gun fan do
you know anything about that well i
don't remember that i don't remember
hearing that obviously he's a big naval
academy guy his father spent so many
years at the naval academy and he loves
that place okay so there you go so so
maybe there's the uh connection there
okay was his father's nickname goose i
don't know i mean
it could be
i don't know
and i guess last one for you here uh in
your sh when you're writing about
chashewski do you just have his name
um
for you to just cut and paste when
you're writing you don't you don't write
it out every single time right i do but
you know what it is the easiest name in
the world to misspell right that third
letter gets everybody they want to go to
the y they don't want to go to that z
after the kr right and so i'll say this
every time i wrote it how many times i
wrote it in the book is about
160 000 words something like that i i
looked at it five times every time just
to make sure oh man i would just have it
on on that cut and paste thing and just
hit you know what the uh
the the
alt
c you know p button and just paste it in
you wrote it every time boom boom boom i
did i did and uh i didn't know i had
that function so i'm
i'm old school you know how to spell it
right now like if i asked you how to
spell it you could knew it oh yeah
[Music]
my gosh well done ian o'connor thanks
for the time i appreciate it thanks
again let's do this down the line take
care you got it everyone should
pre-order that book right now
um that ian o'connor is writing on mike
shachewski where all books are
sold
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here